hey guys and welcome back to the Le H
pan show joining me on the show today we
have freedom Max mist bitcoiner and the
host of the what is money show Robert
breed love welcome how are you I'm doing
good Leia it's good to see you again
it's good to see you why are you here in
Miami well been traveling for a while uh
doing a lot of stuff for the show so I
was in legano for the plan B conference
I was in London for Jordan Peterson's
Arc conference okay doing some
interviews there speaking on a panel
and just got back uh less than a week
ago and I'm passing through on my way to
see some family and then um as it was
telling you offline I'm actually
thinking about moving here so kind of
charting the territory a little bit it's
good you'll love it um you know I think
as as Bitcoin as we become such a such
digital Nomads and I think you can be so
exhausting going to different
conferences and places but Miami I think
gives you everything you need yeah it's
very International which is appealing
and then obviously good weather big
Bitcoin culture yeah um good hustle
culture which is something I'm really
looking to be in like a place that moves
fast works hard um and then there's a
gym here that I love that I was telling
you about so I think it's it's got
everything I need I think you'll love it
and it has a big Bitcoin community and
crypto Community um and there's always
people passing through there's always a
crypto event happening a Bitcoin event
happening so I think it's perfect but um
as of today Bitcoin is at 37 I think 500
$ sorry $37,500 and you know we always
get so caught up in the price crypto
Twitter where we obviously initially
connected Bitcoin Twitter always is
caught up in the price but Bitcoin is so
much more than just the price and so I
want to get your understanding on what
would you say the case is for Bitcoin
why is it so necessary and and why does
that therefore make the price somewhat
irrelevant well I would first say that
the price is actually super relevant
okay um and I don't not in the way that
you should just be focused exclusively
on the price because that belies a lot
of what Bitcoin is right there's a lot
more to it than just the price but the
price is very important right the price
I think is the instrument that commands
the most attention in the world MH like
the price of an asset as it moves it's
basically telling you there is this much
of this thing available and there is
this much demand registered for that
thing so that people are competitively
bidding to obtain the thing and so
you're basically in in prices you have
these little data packets that are
telling you um how scarce and valuable
something is and so it is really
important but I think you need to
dissect actually what prices are one of
the things Bitcoin fixes is price
signals actually so when we're debasing
money you're actually interrupting that
process of people competitively bidding
for things to to clear supply and demand
and you start to create uh credit
bubbles uh you create the uran business
cycle theory that misus expanded on in
the 50s it basically says when you start
to distort these price signals Capital
begins being
allocated not in accordance with the
plans and preferences of individuals but
rather with in accordance with plans and
preferences of the state so literally
all the work that we do to create all of
this stuff around us it's not the
individuals that are doing the work that
are actually dictating where that
Capital ends up and what form it's in
the state via policy and coercion starts
to decide uh you know where tax dollars
are being spent how money's being
printed Etc and so I think that just
distorts reality it it really screws up
incentives because in a system where you
have very strong private property and
you can keep everything that you earn
well then you have a very strong
incentive to be productive and
Cooperative right and have good longterm
trading relationships with people but in
a system where you can profit via
coercion you now have this counter
incentive to be more politicking be more
um deceptive be more all the things that
we associate with all these great
Statesmen right like Trudeau and Putin
everyone like all all the all the states
people so the incentives you know if you
want to talk about why Bitcoin is really
important I could go on and on and on
right as I do on the podcast we've done
like almost 400 episodes at this point
talking about the nature of money the
importance of Bitcoin but if I tried to
sum that up in one
phrase I love the quote that human
nature is like water it takes the shape
of its container and I think the
incentive structures we build for
ourselves are basically the container
that we pour our human nature into and
so right now we have a very flawed
container the fiat currency complex
right where you have as I've described
this it's a basically a pyramid scheme
right so those at the
top benefit at the expense of those at
the bottom so you think about this
like pyramid right this as an actual
hierarchy but at the top of that pyramid
is this spigot of stolen
proceeds all the printed money all the
tax dollars Etc and you have
people through these Mal incentives
scurrying to the top of that pyramid
just trying to get close to the money
printer right get too big to fail or die
trying um get a state subsidy
um get an SBA loan like whatever state
handout you're trying to get you're not
focusing on satisfying the wants of your
customers you're focusing on pandering
to coercive Statesmen right so like it
it messes up the way we act really and
um I think Bitcoin the importance of it
would be as a new container effectively
like so we'd have this hierarchy that
doesn't have this spigot of stolen
proceeds that everyone's fighting each
other to get on top
of um or maybe another way to say it
metaphorically is like you're actually
you're dialing down the valve on that
spigot right there'd be inflation would
be less of a revenue option for the
state so over time I think it really
reorganizes Human Action away from
coercion compulsion violence and towards
cooperation peace and trade so it's a
really big deal but to say something
like this sounds extremely radical I
think people have to do you know the
number that's commonly thrown around is
about 100 hours of research before you
start to see the light and um so that's
why I think that the main advice I can
give people to just study Bitcoin or
study the nature of money I don't expect
you to take such a radical comment at
face value but there is a there's a lot
of depth to this Rabbit Hole to say the
least what would you say some of the key
problems are with the traditional system
I mean I know of course there's money
printing um you know property rights but
can you expand on why those are such
issues yeah the these things are the
same thing by the way and this is a very
important point to grasp is that money
printing is a violation of private
property rights so if you're saving in
dollars that the central bank is
counterfeiting then you're being
plundered by the central bank right
they're stealing your purchasing power
by debasing the currency so as I've
repeated at nauseum and I'll just say it
one more time inflation is legal
counterfeiting counterfeiting is
Criminal inflation central banks are
currency counterfeiting cartels like
that's a really big problem yeah and so
what is property well property is the
socially acknowledged relationship
between an owner and an asset so if if I
take it really philosophical we say what
is justice justice is people getting
what they deserve right this is this is
what this is like an Ideal World right
we talk about Karma and things like this
a lot we ideally would like a world in
which that most people if not everyone
gets what they deserve right so they get
what they take out out what they put in
sort of thing and so if Justice is
people getting what they deserve all
we're saying with private property is
that people keep what they earn right
it's either you built the thing or you
traded the thing you built with someone
else that built a thing
consensually right that's private
property in action the violation of
private property is when you have a
non-consensual exchange so you've just
taken something from someone so I
usually like to boil these down into
making versus taking and we just want a
world again back to that incentive model
we want to tilt the incentive structure
such that people are engaged more in
making which is entrepreneurial
activities consensual trade which is
also peaceful thank goodness it works
out like that by the way it's the moral
alternative is also the most pragmatic
alternative we become the most
productive under pure capitalism and we
become the most
peaceful and away from the other model
which is the systemic violation of
private property through currency
counterfeiting slin flation or Taxation
and I would also throw in there Fiat
regulation right lockdowns MH that's a
violation of private property yeah when
you tell someone because you own
yourself right you intrinsically like no
one else can move my arm I am a
self-owned self- sovereign being as all
are as all all of as are all of
us when you tell someone they can't come
out of their house because there's a you
know Boogeyman plandemic out in the the
world you're violating their private
property so it's not just stealing it's
also incarcerating people and limiting
their freedom of movement action and um
all of these things are just intrinsic I
think to building uh a
rational peaceful civilization so the
the more we can defund the institutions
that do that the better off we all are
and there's a time of yours which I love
and we spoke about this on the last
podcast that we did which is Fiat
induced psychosis and correct me if I'm
wrong but the idea is all the madness
that we see in the world is a result of
corrupt money um so can you explain how
how how is the money corrupt and then
also how does that then trickle down
into all other aspects of of the world
and make everything insane and also what
are some examples of uh Fiat and ju
psychosis with the ball market right
around the corner you do not want to
miss the boat with crypto you need a
reliable crypto exchange that you can
trust and depend on especially if you're
new to crypto you need somewhere that is
simple and also easy to use that is why
we recommend coinex the crypto exchange
is dedicated to providing Professional
Services and top products for a smooth
and enjoyable trading experience coinex
puts the user first and is a trustworthy
and reliable place for newbies the
platform is actually currently
celebrating its sixth anniversary which
is an extreme long time in the new world
of crypto because most exchanges don't
even make it past a few years and what's
more exciting is coinex wants to show
its gratitude and its loyalty to its
users so they've actually launched a
campaign called You Raise Me Up where
they are giving away Rich bonuses and
prizes to its customers and of course
they'll be very special rewards for
newbies so guys make sure you follow
coinex Global on Twitter it's at coinex
and coin X's website so you don't miss
out yeah it's a great question and it's
also a very big one so I'd first like to
credit the inspiration for this line of
thinking to Matias desmit who I had on
the show he wrote a book titled the
psychology of
totalitarianism U the actual term he
uses is mass formation
psychosis I shortened it to mass
psychosis um I don't know if that's
technically accurate or not but it just
makes more sense to me and so he lays
out a number of reasons that
societies historically have given into
you know societies that were
very uh successful right they they'
lasted for a long time they' built up
large stores of capital they had um you
know somewhat Fair rule of law they had
they had Advanced the human Enterprise
let's say but in many times in many
places they had given into this Mass
psychosis which ultimately degenerates
into totalitarianism totalitarianism
would be like the ultimate form of mass
Psych where you've basically deified an
individual right Stalin is God or ma is
God whatever it may be and so he
outlines a number of reasons in his book
that I think are excellent but one that
we talked about on the show together
this was maybe 18 months
ago I was asking him about if the
violation of private property could
contribute to that and my thinking is
you know you look around the world today
especially young people that are really
getting victimized in the current
inflationary
regime you can work two jobs three jobs
right you can hustle your ass off but
the prices of houses keep soaring right
it's um productivity and wages keep
diverging so you can't you're not able
to keep what you earn even if you work
your ass off and so what is that doing
to a young person a young mind is you're
you're almost losing your grip on
reality it's like the social contract is
being broken doing everything that I
learned right save money work hard you
know take care of myself what all the
things yet Society is not
rewarding my action and so at some point
I think people start to become
infuriated with that and obviously when
we say Fiat induced Mass psychosis again
we're talking about fiat currency right
this this counterfeiting of currency
which is the violation of private
property of saf
this is the the big one right this
is so to put some numbers on this that
might be helpful $6 trillion
counterfeited in 2020 by the
US
um $6 trillion the average annual wage
$60,000 so if you divide 6 trillion by
60,000 you get $1 100
million hours of of human time stolen
hope I'm saying this correct I'm sorry
100 million years of human time stolen
if you divide that by 50 productive
years on average per human life right
you work from the age of roughly 20 to
70 then we're talking about 2
million hours worth of productive labor
stolen to the counterfeiting of6
trillion so it's it's it's a massive
theft and I think when you when when the
social contract is is not working for
people in that way it just leads you to
become more unstable psychologically
right you're more desperate right so if
you and another way to think about this
we're all civilized here right we're
sitting here in a nice room somewhat air
conditioned a little warm we've got
water you know all of our basic needs
are met we have the luxury of just
talking to one another and enjoying our
company we don't need to fight over
every sandwich but if we plucked
ourselves out and threw ourselves naked
into the middle of the
Jungle like we would get de civilized
pretty quickly right we'd be desperate
like I've got to eat I like that would
be a a total violation of private
property you just like you were totally
moved to another place all your stuff
was taken you're in the middle of the
Jungle you can't defend yourself from
the wrath of nature you would just be
doing whatever it takes to find shelter
and food and survival
basically inflation and Taxation and all
these forms of theft are just a gradient
along that scale right you're just
pushing people back towards the edges of
the Jungle and not letting them take
control of their own life right Rand
says in Rand said something interesting
that if you can't control the fruits of
your own labor then no other human
rights matter property rights are
foundational to all human rights so it
seems to just make intuitive sense that
if we're violating the basis of human
rights which is private property itself
that human rights start to get shaken up
and then people lose their mind
right and
I don't know you know I don't know where
this goes I think we do have people sort
of deifying the state today they think
that the answer is more
regulation and I just don't think that's
correct I think the answer is more
freedom so Bitcoin obviously you believe
is the answer to all of this but I'm
curious to what extent and in what way
so do you see Bitcoin in the future as a
medium of exchange we live you know we
suddenly have hyperbitcoinization and
everything is obviously um denominated
in Satoshi and Bitcoin or do you see it
as um you know the ultimate store of
value digital property digital gold
where do you see Bitcoin come into play
in in the
future well bitcoin's a lot of different
things to a lot of different people and
we're throwing these different analogies
at it trying to understand it or explain
it and I think that very attempt the
fact that there's so many people
describing Bitcoin in so many different
ways
is an indication of how profound it
really is right this is um similar to
when the internet emerged you know there
were all these weird analogies being
thrown at it it's like oh it's the
information super highway it's a digital
library whatever but none of it really
captured what the internet actually
is um I think you know most
fundamentally it is a the best
implementation of the ancient ideal that
we have from the Magna Carta which was
signed in I think the year 12:15 by King
John life liberty inviable property you
know we inherited that in the United
States Constitution we swapped out
inviable property for the pursuit of
happiness I think that's a mistake but
the the concept
was the government should preserve those
three things only right they should
preserve life we want to create uh a
field of action where people are not
acting violently towards one another
preserve Liberty so they can move about
freely engage in entrepreneurship do
what interests them you know
pursue uh pursue your interest create
businesses create value for others solve
problems creatively Etc encourage
entrepreneurship basically and in that
inherently risky Pursuit be able to keep
everything that you earn right if you
stumble upon a successful solution to a
consumer want and you create a very
successful business well then you should
have the rights to all of the fruit of
that labor that whether it's physical or
cognitive
labor and so Bitcoin is most
fundamentally the hardest form of
property in the sense that I'm
describing it the word property gets
thrown around a lot of different ways a
lot of people think it's just real
estate but that's not what I'm saying
here right again I'm talking about this
socially acknowledged relationship
between owner and asset right so the the
Your Capacity to keep the things that
you earn yeah Bitcoin is the thing that
is it's almost like the most defensible
Bearer asset we've ever had so it's triv
trivially simple and inexpensive to
secure incredibly difficult to
take and so I think that's what it
really is right that humans need
recourse to something that that can't be
taken so all these other analogies and
they're useful don't get me wrong
digital gold very useful because gold
has been like the monetary Bedrock of
the past 5,000 years looking at the
properties of gold what made it good
money I think is a very good prism for
understanding what Bitcoin is I also say
this at nauseum so I won't go through
the whole thing but gold was the most
divisible durable recognizable portable
and scarce asset historically that's why
it became money if you understand those
are the properties that made gold good
money you are better equipped to
understand what makes Bitcoin the best
money we've ever seen it outco competes
gold in all five Dimensions like 100
fold and so these analogies are useful
digital gold the internet of money
uh one way I put this recently is you
know 15 years ago gold and the internet
had a baby and its name is Bitcoin so
that's another just kind of
tongue-and-cheek way to say it but um
most fundamentally it is this idea this
implementation of justice that people
can now go out into the world create
value for others and keep that the the
the value that they create the profits
that they generate and earn you can keep
that in a medium that cannot be
confiscated from you so it's it's very
fundamental to advancing human
civilization So speaking of not
violating property rights um it's an
interesting one because a lot of people
really believe that Bitcoin was created
by some type of government agency the
CIA people point to Putin so firstly
what's your take on that and what's the
probability that Bitcoin was created by
a government agency um and then also who
do you think created bitcoin um I'll
answer the second one first I have no
clue who Satoshi Nakamoto is not even
like an inkling nothing so the best
theory that I've heard was that it was a
collaboration between halin and X
Zabo makes sense right they a lot of
their obviously Halen was the second
adopter of Bitcoin after Satoshi himself
and then a lot of Nick zabo's work goes
into these fields like so these are two
guys that are equipped enough to have
perhaps pulled off a project as profound
as this I've also heard that some of
zabo's uh writing they've done analysis
on his writing style and there's some
matching to Satoshi but you know again
check my facts on all this I don't I'm
not I'm not sure I don't really think it
matters I you know one of the most
important things Satoshi did was
disappear yeah this this cemented the
decentralized mythology of Bitcoin and
the fact that we have Bitcoin now that
can say things like we are all Satoshi
right and the state doesn't have an
individual to centrally Target and
denigrate and
smear um to tarnish the Bitcoin project
I think that's really important um again
humans are kind of religious animals
like we talked about people deifying the
state and deifying
[Music]
authoritarians um the the Bitcoin
creation meth is important it's really
important to cementing it as an actual
decentralized project that no individual
can control now as far as did a
government agency could a government
agency be responsible I actually had an
episode recently that was interesting
with a guy named G money and he talked
i' let you check out the episode I
couldn't rehash at all but he has this
theory that um there were insiders
inside like the NSA the US government
that were trying to create something to
kill Leviathan right the the the state
and obviously the NSA created sha 256
which is something that Bitcoin runs on
I think that's correct someone might
have to fact check me on that as well uh
NSA created some essential cryptographic
feature that Bitcoin uses I didn't know
it was sha 256 I could be wrong about it
but I'm pretty sure that NSA did create
one essential cryptographic element of
Bitcoin I didn't know that um but
it so maybe that's a whole thing that's
his whole theory that there were
insiders said hey this is wrong what the
central bank is in the state is doing
let's create this little project and
push it out into the world or maybe they
just helped it along who knows I thought
that was just a very interesting
conversation it really doesn't matter
though this is the punchline it's like
it doesn't matter people want to say
things like oh NSA invented it totally
bogus scam just meant to usher in
cbdcs and I'm like okay why would the
NSA create a technology that the NSA
cannot
stop to usher in a inferior alternative
which would be a
cbdc it doesn't like it doesn't make
sense and the fact again back to
decentralization like the fact that no
one can control it and no institution
can change the rules that it runs on and
no Central Power can corrupt it or stop
it or even interrupt it for that matter
that's the key value proposition so even
if a central power created it then it
created its own cyanide basically yeah
it created its own poison pill and so
you we could debate about this forever
and ever and ever but at the end of the
day I really don't think it matters
because Tik Tock next block 21 million
the
end you know what's interesting is I I I
think Bitcoin is um and I use this term
lightly somewhat
anti-government just because I think
that to be Pro Bitcoin requires you to
be skeptical of central banks and
government policies right because you
want to be Sovereign over your money you
don't trust what they're doing with your
money and so the whole idea is that
you're skeptical of government so for me
I get a little confused when I see
people who are who are pro Bitcoin
therefore skeptical of government but
are then PR government and not skeptical
of government when it comes to other
issues whether it's like um schooling
education um you know the pandemic um
Taxation and things like that so I saw a
podcast that you did with a really
prominent um bitcoiner um and you know
he's very Pro Bitcoin yet many times
he's been very um Pro government more
government intervention I think on this
particular episode you were debating
taxes with him and you were obviously
anti-taxes to some extent and and he was
Pro taxes so in your in your mind can
you explain to me how can you be a
bitcoiner yet be PR government
intervention in other aspects of Life
yeah I'd like to get a little higher
resolution on the word government first
of all
so it's clear that we have to have
governance of some kind right even your
your homeowners association as a little
micro governance structure so that
people don't have junk in their front
yards in your
neighborhood um and I like to
distinguish that from the state and so
the government is more like how do we
make decisions related to these common
pool
resources um and the state is more like
follow this rule or
else and so I think the real problem in
the world and this is another Fiat
induced issue is that we have when you
the central government has a money
printer
it never stops growing right so we get
less and less localism less and less
local governance and we get more and
more centralized statism because again
if you can just print money you never
incur economic losses you grow forever
right that's like a core problem
so this is where we get into the weeds
of this argument it's like we can't just
say anti-government prover right it's
like okay we need some governance
obviously we need homeowners
associations for instance there's a
bunch of other examples
um but we don't but we need really to be
able to opt in or opt out right and this
is where the localism comes in it's like
you could have certain rules governing a
specific territory if I don't agree with
the rules then what I can do is I can
participate in politics in local
politics and try to change them in a way
that I that I agree with more or I can
exit to another jurisdiction I can opt
out we don't have a lot of that opt out
today you know you would say people oh
move to another country okay in the
United States we have the exit tax if
you have above a $2 million net worth
which isn't that much money anymore you
get taxed on everything you take out of
the us when you say hey Uncle Sam I
don't like the services you're giving me
for the price that you're charging me
I'm going elsewhere taking my business
elsewhere right just like any other free
market participant Uncle Sam puts a gun
to your head and says okay give me x% of
everything above 2 million that's not an
opt out right that's not free market
situation that's the state imposing a
rule on you at the point of a gun like
that's the thing that I think we really
need to eliminate governance not so much
so to get to your question how can
someone be Pro state or Pro government
and pro Bitcoin at the same
time it's complicated because not only
for those reasons right what do you mean
by government are you talking about you
know state are you talking about local
governments government is this globalism
is it localism but also because Bitcoin
is so many different things to so many
different people right Bitcoin
theoretically can be a a treasury asset
for uh a Sovereign Nation like the
United States right the United States
could start to put it on its balance
sheet for instance um does that make
Bitcoin bad all of the sudden I would
say no that's just another organization
just you know Michael sailor's got micro
strategy he puts that on his
corporation's balance sheet well what is
the state the state is just a mega
corporation that specializes in coercion
so it could put Bitcoin on its balance
sheet
too the people that support that like
I'm not sure I would I would have to get
into the details with them it's like
okay what do you mean when you say
you're Pro government you're Pro State
Pro regulation are you talking about
local government are you talking about
central government well let's say I
think it would be very difficult to be
Pro Central statism
and pro Bitcoin at the same time because
again as I said earlier Bitcoin is a
poison pill to centralized statism so
anyone that that shares in that belief I
think you you have some cognitive
dissonance right but that does not
preclude the possibility of being pro
local governance and being pro Bitcoin
okay cognitive dissonance then yes
that's a yeah I think that that makes a
lot of sense um so I'm curious about
these local governments small
jurisdictions I've heard the idea I
think it was safine who who speaks about
like having monarchs and being able to
yeah the monarchy and being able to move
to different jurisdictions if you don't
like it I mean would that even be
realistic and then with the monarchy
they're obviously
unelected so isn't that just like
another dictator centralized power how
how does that work the answer is I have
no idea and that's the great thing
because
Bitcoin Again by making coercion and
theft more expensive basically or less
profitable be more simple you're
shrinking the revenues for the
centralized State and so that's giving
people more of the purchasing power and
productivity that we're creating it's
going into the hands of people that can
now self-organize more effectively
because one they're not out trying to
outrun inflation because inflation is no
longer a thing on a Bitcoin standard and
two because they'd have at least some of
their wealth or they have Rec course to
this hyper portable asset called Bitcoin
so you can more effectively vote with
your feet or vote with your wallet right
if you go to the jurisdiction that
treats you best and then all of the
sudden you have States or governments
more specifically probably more local
because they can't overgrow through the
Fiat
spigot having higher accountability to
the preferences of their customers right
this this power to say no or opt out
this is what keeps every producer in an
economy honest right if you go to buy a
car out here in Miami and the guy's
trying to get a high price out of you
and you're trying to negotiate him down
what's keeping him honest with you is
that you can say no at any point walk
out of that car dealership walk next
door to his competitor and start
negotiating with him right the fact that
we can have these competitive bidding
processes yeah is what keeps prices low
and output and quality high so we don't
have that in this the state today and
that is the problem so what what does a
Bitcoin standard governance model look
like I have no idea but we have a lot
more experimentation we have a lot of
different flavors for a lot of different
people and that's a good thing right
that's more Choice that's more
optionality that's more freedom and
that's you know what bitcoin's all about
I I find that there's we're closer to
One World Government you know than um
separate jurisdictions um you know
particularly in the you know either
you're the west or the East that's it
um and you know I don't think you have
any more rights going from the UK to
America or even Dubai in America I don't
think Dubai has any more rights just
because it's so Pro crypto so yeah no I
think that we we absolutely have zero
Choice um but what's interesting right
now and I and I know that you talk a lot
about this Bitcoin and its ability to
well not Bitcoin let's say uh the Fiat
system and its ability to fund Wars and
encourage Wars and make Wars profitable
right now obviously the US have spoken
about being able to fund both Wars so
fund the war in Europe and the US wants
to fund the war in the Middle East so
can you talk to me about how Bitcoin is
a solution to this and I know it's
really cringe but I always see um you
know somebody on Twitter I think it was
once Max Max Kaiser he like uh took a
picture of uh the Palestinians fighting
and was like Bitcoin fixes this does it
fix
it look it's a
big it's a big leap right and I'm not
going to say that it's wrong as as I
said at the beginning of this
show human Nature's like water it takes
the shape of its container so we do
change over time right we have
become much more civilized much more
moral we have moral intuitions that we
all many of us share today they did not
exist in say ancient Egypt right where
there's Pharaoh God Kings and everyone's
a subject so we have managed to change
uh the cultural Paradigm that we plug
into over time it has evolved it has uh
we have innovated perhaps let's say
culture towards being more peaceful over
time over the long Arc of human
history granted there's been many uh
many inter periods of extreme violence
even regression like the Dark Ages right
we we progress so far and then
civilization takes a few steps back
before we take a few steps
forward but I say all this just to to
make the point that we are there is a
malleability to Being Human that we can
change like we're not doomed to just be
forever these Apes battling over
territory you know we have we're imbued
with rationality we can share ideas
especially fast you know there's more
liquidity of ideas today than ever
before in the digital age like we can do
this and then boom it's all over the
world at zero cost right the ideas can
spread like wildfire in the digital age
and there's a lot more voices
participating right so you have a lot
more dialogue and
discourse and so this thing with Bitcoin
is like
okay you could rerun say um like a World
War II example where when Hitler invades
Poland as soon as they surrender what is
his the next thing Hitler does well
Hitler goes to the central bank and he
raids the gold because guess what war is
very expensive he just spent a ton of
money funding his troops to get him over
there and Conquer Poland what does he
need first the gold so he can go and
refund the war effort and continue right
now if you just rerun that scenario on a
Bitcoin standard as a thought
experiment and say we still have states
that are at war with one another that
hasn't gone away even though we're on a
Bitcoin standard Hitler Blitz cre comes
in conquers Poland he goes straight to
the central
bank and oh but they've store stored
everything in Bitcoin in a multisig he
can't just grab it and take it and leave
and go back to business there's an
unseizable asset here that he can't
take so how then would the Hitler War
Machine be funded in that scenario and
again this is a thought experiment I'm
not saying it's deterministic and that's
exactly how it would happen but there
there's a very deep importance to the
idea of things
being of having a medium that is very
expensive to violate via violence or
coercion right if it's
economically if it's unprofitable right
the war all of a sudden the war that was
profitable on a gold standard is not
profitable on a Bitcoin standard if you
don't have profitability you don't have
people doing it people do whatever do
will do whatever is profitable right
people do horrible things for profit
people kill people and sell their organs
for
profit and and just to be clear Wars for
profit just to be clear why why is war
profitable on a gold standard but not on
a Bitcoin standard the seiz ability of
the
gold and I'm not saying it's it's not a
binary it's not war is profitable then
war is not profitable it's less
profitable on a Bitcoin standard because
Bitcoin is more difficult to seize if
not impossible to seize you could still
go to war of Natural Resources right but
as the war is encroaching the like
people refugees that are fleeing right
typically they leave behind all their
wealth right it's they would leave their
buildings leave the capital the
equipment the whatever they owned they
would flee to escape the war zone what
if those refugees had access to a hyper
portable uninflated digital form of
wealth you know so Capital could could
kind of run away from war zones more
efficiently and more easily and this
lowers the profitability of war and I
think therefore lowers its prevalence so
I mean it's a bit abstract and
theoretical obviously we have no
historical example of this
um the the book on this and the
bibliography to this book The sovereign
individual I think is very useful there
is a literature on the economics of
violence and it's it's telling right
humans have changed the way they self
organize as the our ability to it as the
profitability of attack or defense
changes the shape of our society has
changed in lock step and so what we're
seeing with Bitcoin is we have a a Great
Leap Forward in the defensibility of
purchasing power right you can put your
private keys on your brain you can cross
a border with a billion dollars on your
brain you have total plaus total
plausible deniability right they can
search you they can cavity search you
like they're not going to see your do
you believe that though like sorry just
to interrupt you on your train of
thought there how accurate is that
though because I'm understanding that
like
more they're building more software
systems which allow allow government
agencies to track and identify who owns
what you mean uh on bitcoin all
cryptocurrencies just by looking at an
address I I don't know this is AML and
kyc and if you buy Bitcoin through a I
mean like non kic Bitcoin well if you
put it through a
mixer then you can anonymize
yourself so the Privacy Technologies are
improving there are ways to privatize
your staff
uh it's not for everyone right you have
to be somewhat technically proficient
but there are ways to anonymize your
Holdings and I think it'll get easier
over time and it gets easier in line
with if governments say um are acting on
that knowledge more and more and they
start blacklisting people that have
bought Bitcoin through kyc exchanges or
they're tracking people that have
acquired it non kyc obviously if you
acquire it directly via mining that's
very difficult for a government to track
it's like you you generated uh the
Bitcoin organically effectively and like
they they're none the wiser unless
you're a publicly traded Mining Company
right maybe there's some tracking there
yeah
um but if governments are acting on that
information and they're coercing people
and they're sending them scary grams and
all of this well guess what happens the
demand for privacy Tech goes up and we
start producing more better easier
cheaper privacy Tech and um yeah I think
people are just always going to use the
tools that the best tools that are
available to them and this is going to
drive innovation in in privacy Tech
and get more people out of the eyes the
eye of Sauron so to speak do you think
that there's a genuine concern that
governments could crack down on bitcoin
because they're already cracking down on
privacy coins I think Monera was de
listed from an exchange obviously we saw
what happened with tornado cash
um I saw crypto.com now um you have to
you have to kyc the wallet that the
money comes from so even if it doesn't
come from an exchange but it comes from
you know um a non-custodial wallet you
you have to kyc yourself otherwise the
money gets halted so governments are
doing everything that they can to um
eliminate any privacy so do you think
Bitcoin is at any risk from any
government well I mean this is is the
magic of decentralization all right um
so purely in terms of privacy again I
would just defer to like the last
argument is the more you violate
people's privacy or act on um
information of individual holders use
that against them you're just going to
incentivize people to mix their coins
use different privacy Tech
Etc um but as far as a government
attacks on bitcoin and is that a
risk I think the recent mining ban by
China is a very illustrative example of
the magic of decentralization it's
like China is 1.4 billion people the CCP
is the most iron fisted authoritarian
regime that's ever existed in the
history of the human race right the most
technically Advanced the most well-armed
the most oppressive the most
organized um the most
controlling they outlawed Bitcoin mining
on their own territory
yeah and at that time about 50% of the
global hash rate was coming out of
China two years later I think now we're
roughly two years later still 25% of
bitcoin's global hash rate is coming out
of China so if that regime if the CCP
with its strongest iron fist in human
history cannot squash Bitcoin mining
which is the most obviously physically
represented aspect of Bitcoin it's where
the rubber meets the proverbial Road
right you actually have physical capital
in physical places which is the
specialty of government um if they can't
stop this incentive structure from
people people are still mining Bitcoin
in China it's still happening yeah is it
the government is it government insiders
like again we use these terms as like
models of
simplification China's not like one
indivisible aggregate that moves you
know uh moves as one unit basically
there's billions of people in there
there's billions of power factions and
billions of uh competing families and
interest so whoever can Grease the skids
and get the Bitcoin mining done gets it
done and it's still happening that's the
most iron fisted government or state on
Earth so if they can't stop the most
physical aspect of Bitcoin which is
Bitcoin mining then what state can so
this is the real magic of
decentralization all the other examples
you gave tornado cash uh Etc why are
they getting squashed because they're
not decentralized right right there's
one team there's one group there's one
headquarters there's a one development
team um so states are really good at
cutting the heads off of centralized
organizations they states don't know how
to deal with decentralization bitcoin's
the most decentralized organization
humans have ever had and we've spoken
about states which are anti- Bitcoin or
you know hostile towards Bitcoin but of
course there are are other countries
which are very Pro Bitcoin so obviously
El Salvador adopted Bitcoin um what's
your opinion on that whole experiment do
you think it's been successful so far
and also which country do you think is
next to adopt Bitcoin so I'd first say I
don't have a strong opinion on El
Salvador I've only visited for three or
four days earlier this year it does seem
like bu's cleaned up a lot of crime yeah
right and
the locals that I spoke to there um you
know
entrepreneurs just selling street food
right like an old lady selling street
food yeah she was saying before buelli
five times a day these gangsters would
come around and extort her for money wow
they called it lenta they had to pay the
rent to these gangsters wow
after buelli none of that right so that
has been successful but that is not
related to bitcoin per se I mean maybe
his principles or whatever have
something to do with that I don't I I
don't know I don't know the guy
um making Bitcoin legal Tinder I don't
think that's so first of all I don't
like the idea of legal tender again this
is a violation of private property
telling people what money they have to
use I don't agree with that you should
just let the market
decide and I don't think it's terribly
useful at this stage in bitcoin's
evolution because it's not purchasing
power stable in the short run obviously
um now in the long run I think Bitcoin
is the most purchasing power stable
asset will'll ever have because it has a
fixed Supply but you don't need to force
people to use it as a medium of exchange
to bootstrap adoption I think the use of
Bitcoin as a medium of exchange comes
naturally as it appreciates as a store
value basically the more its market
capitalization grows the lower its
volatility becomes and people that have
large unrealized gains in their
positions have incentive to spend it
right if I bought Bitcoin at a dollar
and it's $37,000 today I have a huge
incentive to spend if I bought it at
30,000 I have much lesser of an
incentive to spend so the market also
sorts that out
um from and I don't know a lot about
this but from what I'm heard what I have
heard from Max and Stacy the Securities
Law framework that El Salvador has put
in place is very Pro Bitcoin and anti-
shitcoin which I think is a good thing
again I haven't read it myself self I
don't know the details but the idea of a
government having a pro Bitcoin
Securities Law framework um should work
in that country's favor and also should
honor human Freedom frankly if you're
giving people access to bitcoin and um
you know the ability to create
businesses and securities that that
honor that uh ability to interact with
Bitcoin I think that's a very useful
thing for human Freedom which country do
you think is next to it legal tender I
have no idea I have no idea
um humans transmit culture via
imitation I don't know who's going to
imitate El Salvador next but I would
think that it's going to kind of work
its way up from the bottom right El
Salvador is a very small country very
small
GDP small population relative to the
other 200 some odd countries I would
expect it to move from the smaller
countries to the medium countries to the
larger countries just by nature of how
fast a smaller country can move I would
also expect and this is sort of
paradoxical or ironic I don't know
authoritarian regimes can move
faster and you might see another pivot
in China at some point to say hey we
have a we Decades of central planning
have created an overc capacity of energy
production in China that they don't have
anything to do with it right they have
these ghost cities like it's just they
have an excess capacity for energy
production why is not all of that going
into Bitcoin mining right now it could
literally monetize all this extra
capacity you built through Central
planning and enroot your country so if
the CCP is smart then they'll figure
that out it's not that complicated right
you're just letting money burn when
you're not allocating these energy
assets to the production of Bitcoin if
it's not being sold on the market right
it's just it's curtailed or unused
energy um you might see a larger
authoritarian country move a little bit
faster than say the US which is in
Democratic woke gridlock yeah we are in
Democratic woke with gridlock a great
way to put it um but what's interesting
as well is that a lot of the greatest
investors of all time you know people
like Warren Buffett you have the likes
of Charlie Munga um they can't get on
board with Bitcoin you know Warren
Buffett called it rat poison uh Peter
shiff anytime Bitcoin moves Peter shiff
is like it's all going to come crashing
down you know so I'm curious what's your
take why do you think these individuals
just refuse to get on board with Bitcoin
do you think it's because it goes
against their own personal interests
or are they just old and they don't get
it human Nature's like water takes the
shape of its container these guys are
talking their book 40% of Burkshire
hathway I think is Fiat Bank
stocks uh obviously shiff is in the gold
business um that's seems pretty obvious
I actually think Munger is right though
or was it Munger or Buffett that said
the rat poison Buffett Buffett Buffet's
right
Buffet Buffett's right Bitcoin is is R
poison why
is kills the rats central banks are the
rats it's you know what I've never
actually like internalize that Bitcoin
is rat poison that's a good thing yeah
called it um I I've
always rothbart often describes the
state these the state the Central Bank
these other systematic violators of
private property it's basically a
parasite host
relationship if you don't have
productive Market actors creating wealth
then there's nothing to confiscate right
so if the if the market were to Die the
the parasite would automatically die so
state m is Like A Parasite on the free
market effectively so I've described
Bitcoin as parasiticide it actually is
killing the parasite again back to this
whole idea of the poison pill you're
just giving people recourse to something
that is not amenable to the revenue
model of the parasite which is to steal
and so when you make stealing more
difficult you make it less profitable
you make the business of stealing less
prevalent so Bitcoin is rat poison
that's actually so fascinating I never I
never internalize that um I think they
need to come up with a different a
different saying um and then you know we
started this interview talking about the
price and I think something which has
really been pushing up the price is this
um spot ETF the the spot Bitcoin ETF
which is supposedly coming um so firstly
when do you think that'll be approved
what impact do you think that will have
on bitcoin and then my last question is
are you concerned that that might make
Bitcoin more centralized because now you
have all these major institutions buying
up more and more Bitcoin I mean Black
Rock already owns practically everything
um to put it um in a simplistic way so
do you think that could make Bitcoin
more centralized so when I have no idea
right we've been talking about ETFs for
years in the Bitcoin space I don't
really care I'm not that interested in
it um I do think it will be a major
widening of capital channels flowing
into Bitcoin right there's a lot of a
lot of
Institutions um a lot of pools of
capital that cannot access Bitcoin for
one reason or another either their
mandate or um whatever it may be an ETF
is something that's much more accessible
for most of these Capital Pools so I
would expect to see upon approval
whenever it happens there would be a lot
more capital inflow into Bitcoin of cool
Sam as far as the centralization
concerned you
know the
concentration of ownership of Bitcoin
obviously through a black rock ETF could
become more concentrated in the hands of
the shareholders of or the the LPS or
GPS in these funds that black rock
operates but that bears no influence on
the core consensus protocol of Bitcoin
itself so this this is a common sort of
misunderstanding people think that oh if
you concentrate the ownership of Bitcoin
into fewer hands then they'll increase
the supply or they'll change the block
size or they'll do this or that it's
like that's not how Bitcoin works right
nodes
choose Miners and force it doesn't
matter who actually owns the Bitcoin
you're not voting you're not voting for
The Core consensus protocol through the
owning of Bitcoin so even Satoshi with a
million Bitcoin could not reappear and
be like hey guys it's a 42 million cap
now you know like it just wouldn't work
so that is much less of a concern to me
and again back to the poison pill
analogy I think a lot of the money
inside of black rock
is
wealth earned earned earned is not the
right word wealth
acquired um through shares owned in
central banks and other such
institutions centered on coercion
compulsion theft
violence um I think that the
monetization of Bitcoin which would be
accelerated by Black Rock ETF is going
to undermine those
businesses so it's dissolving you know
it's things like Black Rock won't exist
I think on a Bitcoin standard or at
least won't be as powerful and as
prevalent now it's not to say that just
perfectly fixes it because obviously if
they acquire a lot of Bitcoin at a low
price and Bitcoin monetizes then okay
those same rich people that were Rich
from you know theft and and grift before
are still rich but at least they can't
impose the same old Shenanigans and
games and and theft on the Bitcoin
standard so it's not you know there is
no perfect fix human history is a is a
mess right it's a crucible of violence
and theft and lying the best we can do
is introduce something like a new
incentive structure that can hopefully
help us correct our our behavior and so
um Black Rock ETF noide when I think it
is it's an accelerant to bitcoin's
monetization and not a threat to its
decentralization so you're making a
distinction between um owning a lot of
Bitcoin versus mining the Bitcoin which
makes a lot of sense um but this is
something someone said to me the other
day and I actually know didn't know what
to respond to them so it'll be
interesting to hear you take what if
somebody like Black Rock started buying
up all the different mining pools um and
so now they have more than a 51%
ownership of all the Bitcoin
mining could they
then then it's centralized and they can
then change the the laws of the network
and the and the math of the network is
that a possibility you know I would
Point
people to the Sailor series which is the
first series I did on my show and
sailor's way smarter than I am about
this and he walks through the math of
like what that would look like not Black
Rock specifically but if you wanted to
51% attack the network yeah well here's
how much equipment you'd have to buy
here's how much electricity you need
it's difficult but someone like Black
Rock could afford it in theory but
there's also these temporal like it
would there's lead time like you need to
be able to B to mobilize all of this
equipment you're saying if Black Rock
just went out and bought them
immediately um I don't know I guess
that's a good thought experiment
but I um I think in general Bitcoin
mining Network responds adversarially so
if that
happens um you're going to create the
ultimate arms race to build more Bitcoin
miners right if black Rock's getting
into the game would be C and they're
buying all the Bitcoin Miners and that's
the largest Capital pool one of the
largest Capital Pools on Earth wouldn't
every competitor to that Capital pool
immediately look to do the same thing
and so you just get a lot more Bitcoin
mining a lot more places a lot more
security for the network a lot more
decentralization interesting so yeah I
don't know this is the weird thing about
Bitcoin it's like I've called it a
positive Vortex of incentives it's like
no matter which way you attack this
thing it just always pays you to compete
honestly in the marketplace yeah and it
it just resists all control It suffers
no
Kings it's a very strange thing
interesting yeah I never thought about
it like that so just finally what are
you working with at the moment what do
you have like do you have any
interesting guests coming up on the what
is money show what do you what are you
focused on right now yeah so I'm
actually interviewing uh an author that
I've that orange pilled me before
Bitcoin I guess not orange pilled he
black pilled me on Central Banking G
Edward Griffith okay I'm sorry g g
Edward Griffin he's the author of the
creature from from J Island which is a
book about the Inception of the Federal
Reserve the nature of money um the
history of Central Banking it's really
good it's a free audio book on YouTube
okay they have an Abridged version it's
really good um I'm talking to him
tomorrow so I'm really excited about
that been trying to get him on the show
for like a year and that's really my
focus focusing on the podcast I want to
start doing more inperson episodes
especially after I reloc
relocate uh doing some writing and I've
been doing some public speaking um I
interviewed some guests at the events
that I mentioned was it Lugano and and
Arc so that's been it just uh working on
the show trying to orange pill the world
and um life's pretty good what did you
do before Bitcoin so I had a degree in
accounting and finance and I was
basically a career CFO and then I ran
ran a hedge fund immediately before
starting the podcast so basically been
an accounting and finance guy most of my
career got it that's interesting I
didn't know that yeah so Bitcoin is the
Natural Evolution of that triple entry
bookkeeping yeah yeah exactly well I'm
excited to check out um your podcast I'm
going to with your with your guest I'm
going to look at that book I haven't
haven't actually heard of it what was it
called again the creature the creature
from jaal Island the creature from ja
Island I need to read that yeah yeah you
know I don't know if you like Audi books
but the Audi book's done really well on
YouTube and it's I think it's in a
bridged version too so it's only maybe 5
hours okay wow and uh it's really good
good I I think I have to credit him too
because I read this book a long time ago
I was probably 20 years old so almost 20
years ago and I didn't I relistened to
it maybe six months ago the audio book
and he actually has a chapter in the
book what is money he goes into the
nature of money I I was like I don't
know I subconsciously just named the
show because of that but I guess I
should give him some credit because he
has a very excellent explanation of the
nature of money yeah that's that's so
interesting well I want to thank you so
much for coming on the show um for me
thank you so much you know I know you're
only in Miami for a short period of time
so it's been great to grab you while
you're here yes and yeah it's been such
a good conversation thank you thank you
for having me and where can people find
you and follow everything that you're
doing yeah so you can find me at what is
money podcast.com and then Twitter is my
biggest social platform which is at
breed love22 bwe d l o v
e22 thanks for coming on the show thanks
for having me if you enjoyed this podast
please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe and stay tuned
because we have a lot more coming